stop stop
stop i have a right to stop you because
you're being suspicious okay turn around
turn around turn around let go
no i am an introvert boundaries that i
am speaking
stop testing up stop relax i'm going
home relax or i'm going to have to
change this situation
stop leave me alone
i'm going home leave me alone just a few
of the final words spoken by 23 year old
elijah mclean
he never would make it home that body
camera footage chronicles his fatal
encounter with police
in aurora colorado we're now learning
through the findings of an independent
investigation that police had no
justification
to stop or use force against that young
man officers stopped mclean on august 24
2019 after someone reported a suspicious
person in the area
from there according to the report
several crucial errors were made
including
paramedics sedating him with ketamine
without first properly observing him
the report also found that none of the
officers stated that they thought
maclean had committed a crime
was committing a crime or about to
commit a crime nothing
from there police used a choke hold on
maclean and he was injected with a
grossly high dosage of ketamine
the young man lost consciousness and was
taken off life support
six days later as i'm telling the story
you must have known how it would play
out you knew he would die in the end
sadly in fact you probably had to remind
yourself which black man it was that
died at the hands of a police officer
was it george floyd was it eric garner
it's all running together right
police officers former and current in
uniform and out continue to get away
with killing black men and women so how
does it happen
who what is protecting these officers
look no further than the legal doctrine
of qualified
immunity it's one of the many factors
that make it nearly impossible
to hold police officers accountable for
wrongdoing
no personal liabilities officers are
shielded from answering for their
potentially allegedly illegal and
unconstitutional acts
unless the victims can show that the
violations of their rights
was quote clearly established
clearly established what does that even
mean it means that the victim must
identify
an earlier decision by the supreme court
or a federal appeals court
in the same jurisdiction holding the
precisely the same conduct
under the same circumstances is illegal
or unconstitutional
if none exists hey presto the officer is
immune
it's nearly impossible to win but now
there's a new campaign to make it easier
to sue cops who break the law
and we've got the scoop on two of the
men backing the campaign
the founders of ben and jerry's ice
cream ben cohen
and jerry greenfield who are
long-standing campaigners
on social justice issues and they both
join me now gentlemen thank you so much
for coming on the show tonight
uh last summer uh in last summer
colorado where elijah mcclain died
became the first state to end qualified
immunity after george floyd was
killed by police officers other states
are considering doing it too
how did you both get involved in this
campaign and why
you know like like millions of other
americans
we've been outraged at the killing
and the murder of unarmed black men
by the police and then we're doubly
outraged when
the police get off scot-free and
so it all came to a head uh
i guess like for so many other americans
after george floyd
died and we looked into it
and uh you know read some articles and
and saw this uh open letter that the
players coalition
professional athletes 400 of them had
written to congress
urging them to pass this bill to
overturn
qualified immunity and we decided that
uh we really had no choice but to join
that effort
and then we got 700 business leaders to
also sign on to a similar letter and
we've been working on it ever since
yeah you know it it's now you've got
sorry go on well i was going to say it's
a chance to move from
protest to policy we saw all the
protests
now is an opportunity to actually make
change
and to make it stick you know as you
said there's
lots of activity at the state level
we're also working at the federal level
and what's interesting about this
campaign to end
qualified immunity is the broad
support that it has it has cross
ideological
support not just from the aclu
and the naacp legal defense fund but
also
the cato institute and the institute for
justice
yes that's a very good point about how
different factions on different parts of
the spectrum are identifying this as a
problem
ben supporters of the police might argue
that officers need some type of legal
protection they have to make quick
decisions in a matter of seconds
mistakes will happen and therefore they
should get some protection from lawsuits
what's your response to that kind of
argument
police already have very strong
constitutional
protections and you know police
are the only element of our society
that we allow to use lethal force
in our name and they need to be held
more accountable not less so many of
these cases
of uh instances where police are
murdering unarmed black men they're not
issues of split-second decision making
they're not issues of
life or death for the cop so many of
these black
young men have been shot in the back and
so it's not it's not that what you're
talking about it's just
unreasonable uh immunity
for police
yeah no it's a good point it's it's the
it's the extent of it where you cannot
get anything done against them because
of this doctrine
uh jerry on your website uh you write
the insurrection at the capitol was a
dramatic and shocking reminder
that white supremacy and racism are
still ingrained in our country america's
unwillingness
to acknowledge and atone for nearly 400
years of slavery and legalize
segregation
continues to rip the moral fabric of
society apart we must have the courage
to confront the truth
you both have also pointed out in the
past that this is not just
a problem for black americans white
people need to be stepping up
oh absolutely
you go german uh
i i think to a degree white people are
stepping up but we have to understand
that
this is not just a black problem it's a
white
problem as well and in our country it's
white
people who have the power and if we're
going to make
changes for justice for a more
equitable country white people have to
be taking the lead on this as well
uh yes and and and the problem is that
when you talk in these terms
people say you're being divisive
polarizing we hear that a lot from the
right
neither of you have been afraid to take
on controversial issues whether it's
racism i know you're also campaigning on
minimum wage increase
reparations for slavery ben what do you
say to companies and business leaders
who are afraid to take controversial
political stance they think it'll hurt
their bottom line what do you say to
them
we're campaigning for justice uh
life liberty the persona happiness
equality and fairness basic american
values
uh all i can say is that the experience
of ben and jerry's
has been that the more stands like this
that we take
the more ice cream we sell
people want to solve this problem
people believe in fairness and equality
people hate the idea that
uh people are getting killed because of
the color of their skin
yeah it's very true and jerry would you
agree with that were there times
i know you both don't run the ice cream
company but there are times when you
were in charge
and you were taking kind of left-wing
progressive
radical positions by american political
standards was that time when there was
pressure look don't do that it's going
to hurt sales
well i the first thing we need to
understand is that
these are not left-wing crazy ideas
these are
humanistic values that support
all people good point in country uh
you know certainly not everybody agrees
with the stands ben jerry's takes and
the company hears
letters emails whatever but as ben
said when you stand up for your values
people respect that and uh
the company continues to thrive you know
the company came out with a statement
after the murder of george floyd that we
must dismantle
white supremacy it pulled no punches
it said straight ahead and the company
got
incredible accolades for being honest
and forthright and not
looking for the mushy middle on things
indeed ben let me ask you this what do
you want i know you've been
very political i know you were the
co-chair of the bernie sanders 2020
campaign
both of you have fought for a lot of
political causes what do you want for
your legacy to be that you fought for
all these political causes
i thought you were responsible for
creating some of the world's most iconic
and popular ice creams
what what when you're looking back on
your life and career and achievements
what's going to take the top spot
well i haven't really been thinking much
about my legacy uh
you know i when i was a little kid well
no i guess i wasn't a little kid i was a
teenager
you know i was thinking what i wanted on
my tombstone
is he tried you know
i i think that we need to stand up for
justice it's not it it's the
responsibility
of everybody it's not the responsibility
of
activists it's not the responsibility of
uh you know people working in
non-profits it's the responsibility
of everyone and
i don't know that's you know when you
see injustice
you have three choices you can either
ignore it
you can complain about it or you can do
something about it
i feel better doing something about it
very well put uh we're gonna have to
leave it there we're
out of time uh thank you so much both of
you coming on the show sadly it's the
end of the show so we have to wrap this
up
i'm gonna go off and binge on a tub of
chocolate therapy
but it was great to talk to you both
about an issue like criminal justice
reform and policing reform appreciate
you finding the good fight thanks so
much
ben and jerry appreciate it
hi i'm mehdi hassan thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe
below to stay up to date on the day's
biggest stories thank you for watching